Врятувати центр Львова, з одного боку,
від пластикових вікон та інших сучасних технологій,
якіруйнують роботу стародавніх майстрів.
А з іншого – від занепаду і відсутності ремонту як такого.
Саме в цьому допомагає команда німецьких майстрів та архітекторів.
З 2009 року вони зберігають
архітектурну спадщину міста за дорученням німецького уряду.
Так зсередини виглядав цей 200-річний будинок рік тому…
Темно і небезпечно.
Сходи могли провалитися у глибокий підвал разом з тими, хто піднімається.
Тут ми реставруємо усю сходову клітину.
Ці сходи на першомуповерсі були настільки понівечені,
що нам довелося їх повністю розбирати.
Це доволі складна, здебільшого ручна робота.
Минулого року Німецьке товариство міжнародної співпраці GIZ
отримало 10 заявок на реставрацію ось таких
сходів від мешканців центру Львова.
А обрали лише 3. Ті, що маютьархітектурну цікавість,
і де місцева влада, а також мешканці будинку
гарантували співфінансування.
В цьому випадку реставрація коштує 1 мільйон 300 тисяч гривень,
з яких 100тисяч виділено з місцевого бюджету,
а усі 12 мешканців внесли по тисячі гривень.
Підтримали, тому що сходова клітка
ніколи не була реставрована,
вона була латана-перелатана
і потребувала ремонту.
Німецьке товариство GIZ за 8 років, що триває проект,
допомогло реставрувати понад тисячу різних об’єктів:
від вікон і балконів до внутрішніх двориків та брам.
Для цього німці навчили майже 600 місцевих
ремісників дещо забутим в Україні технологіям реставрації.
Довелося докласти багато зусиль,
щоб витягнути те красиве дерево,
яке було під старими шарами фарби.
Використали матеріали ті,
які переважно використовувалися тоді,
коли ця брама булазроблена.
Цього року проект з оновлення Львова завершується.
Німецьке товариство продовжить допомагати,
але вже з логістикою розвитку міста,
з тим, як ефективно витрачати наявні бюджетні кошти,
аби продовжувати реставрацію.
В Україні зараз триває реформа з децентралізації,
і тепер в містах залишається більше коштів.
Тобто, є деякі гроші,
але для їх використання необхідний якісний менеджмент.
І я вважаю, що від цього менеджменту і залежить,
як ефективно будуть використовуватися кошти
і на розвиток міста, і на реставрацію.
У міському бюджеті кожного року передбачається
в середньому сім мільйонів гривень на різні проекти з реставрації.
Влада обіцяє продовжувати німецьку ініціативу.
Львів’яни теж не хочуть сидіти склавши руки.
В цьому будинку, приміром, вже створили ОСББ
і вирішили оновлювати його далі.